[Music]
hi I'm here with Chris law to learn more
about how to protect highly sensitive
data for being exfiltrated how do you
think happy to be here so I've seen a
lot of headlines over the last year
about big data breaches and they seem to
be getting bigger and bigger what's
going on yes
any company storing sensitive data needs
to be ready to protect against data
breaches and so when you say highly
sensitive data what do you mean exactly
highly sensitive data can be things like
social security numbers credit card
numbers or patient data this includes
things like PII that's personally
identifiable information financial
information or pH I and that's protected
health information but high sensitive
data could really be any data that your
company deems to be sensitive but the
good news is Google cloud can help
protect this data I'll show you how so
let's say you're building your finance
app and your partner is sending you a
bunch of data the partner we're sending
you both sensitive data in red here and
non sensitive data in green got it so I
really want to keep that red golf-ball
secure exactly now the easiest way to
get this data from the partner is to
create a public bucket in Google Cloud
and give them access to it so now as you
can see the partner is setting the
sensitive data and non sensitive data
all into this one bucket but there's a
problem with that setup and it's that
unauthorized parties can get access to
these public buckets and can accelerate
the data and any exposure of say social
security numbers or credit card
information put you and your company in
the headlines but the good news is
developers like yourself can use Google
clouds I did an access management system
or I am to restrict access to the bucket
that stores this sensitive data so how
does I am work with I am as a developer
you can control exactly which users have
access to the new restricted bucket and
each user will have to securely
authenticate in order to get any access
to data right so as a developer I can
just lock this bucket down so only a few
people can access it exactly anyone
trying to get access to data in your
restricted bucket needs to be authorized
before they can get access to any
sensitive data so I have this new
restricted bucket with limited access
how do I get the social security number
data into that bucket great question
well let's take a look at how you can do
it one way you can sort this social
security number data into this
restricted bucket is to do it manually
the problem with this approach is that
it might make a mistake and categorize
the data wrong so in this example I
might accidentally miss categorize the
social security number data and put it
into the public bucket exposing it to
the wrong people God for highly
sensitive data like this it makes sense
to automate this sensitive data
classification process as much as
possible and that's what developers use
Google clouds data loss prevention or
DLP API for DLP can identify over 90
plus different types of common sensitive
data types like Social Security numbers
and credit card numbers so with DLP
enabled now when the partner sends you
data DLP you will automatically identify
the social security numbers and
automatically put that data into the
restricted bucket amazing pretty cool
yeah so now that we've automated this
process we've got the sensitive data all
going into the restricted bucket and
only a few select users have access to
it great so kind of launched my app now
not just yet
this set up works fine as long as the
partner sends the data into the right
API but let's say they accidentally
email through a bunch of sensitive
social security number data so over here
we have a bunch of emails white golf
balls and emails with sensitive data
which are red golf balls anyone who
could receive this email can download
the social security number data to their
machine or forward it to a personal
drive and this makes it much more likely
to be exposed so how can we keep this
social security number data out of
inboxes to handle this problem you can
use Google clouds data loss prevention
technology in G suite so with G suite
DLP setup the social security number
data within the emails gets
automatically detected and moved into a
quarantine bucket and so now that social
security data doesn't have my inbox
exactly and once the data is moved into
the quarantine bucket admins can review
and handle it more securely
so we've got the social security number
data going securely into this restricted
bucket and now only a few select users
can access it but what's to stop one of
these legitimate users from just
stealing the data right great questions
insider attacks are also a threat so
even if you are putting the data in a
secure environment the user who is
granted access that data may have
malicious intent and might try to
exfiltrate the data leaks like this can
be contained and controlled using Google
clouds VPC service controls with VPC
service controls we can set up a secure
access zone that acts as a perimeter
around the sensitive data
so even insiders can't move the data out
so even a user I granted legitimate
access to would not be able to
exfiltrate that data that's right what
if an admin goes in and just changes
these settings with Google clouds for
SETI open source security tools you can
set up an alert so when an admin makes
any changes to sensitive data settings
an alert can be sent to cloud security
command center so that even admin access
can be monitored Wow
so are we ready to launch the app now
well let's take a look at your finance
app the partner is sending you social
security number data and it's all being
categorized in the right bucket there's
a secure access zone around the data and
even if the partner sends social
security number data via email that data
is automatically quarantined I think
you're ready to launch your app great
well Chris thanks for showing me how
developers and companies can protect
highly sensitive data like this with
Google cloud my pleasure
you